cet oiseau de proie vraiment sec et
reconnu pour être assez chill ceci n'est
pas un documentaire mais une publicité
pour protéger la langue française à
l'aide d'anglissisme c'est le pari
audacieux de la publicité que le
gouvernement québécois diffuse depuis
hier
à l'UQAM les étudiants prennent
connaissance de la vidéo qui fait
d'abord sourire je la trouve plutôt
drôle en fait puis réfléchir oui ça ne
fait réaliser que c'est des mots qu'on
utilise souvent puis ça nous de faire
attention pour éviter le déclin du
français mais la jeunesse se sentait
justement ciblés par le choix des
anglicismes j'ai l'impression qu'ils
vise juste notre groupe puis qui
peut-être nous accuse de déclin de
français
les ados si on veut les culpabiliser je
suis pas sûr qu'on a la bonne cible le
ton humoristique n'a d'ailleurs pas
convaincu les oppositions à Québec moi
je voudrais pas qu'on fasse porter le
poids de l'avenir de la langue française
sur la façon dont on peut parfois
utiliser des angles ici la linguiste
Nadine Vincent qui a comptabilisé cette
anglicisme dans cette publicité de 45
mots il voit l'illustration d'un avenir
sombre du français au Québec le passage
d'une si grande quantité d'anglicis dans
la langue soignée
c'est une
caricature ou un avertissement de ce
qu'on peut risquer
mais le message atteint-il le public
visé si l'objectif c'est de générer des
conversations puis générer une prise de
conscience la publicité elle a le
potentiel certainement de l'atteindre
cette publicité qui fait énormément
réagir a peut-être même déjà atteint sa
cible en croire le ministre Roberge
l'essentiel c'est qu'on débattre la
place du français puis qu'on soit tous
interpellé comprennent conscience de la
fragilité du français mais malgré que
c'est ce qu'il se chasse soit insane
parlez-en bien par les en mal mais par
les angles en français ici Jean-Philippe
house Radio-Canada Montréal